[موسيقى]
انا اسمي غاده سابا اردنيه مسيحيه بنت من
ثلاث بنات لعائله لم تنجب غيرهن ضررت بعد
وفاه اختي شقيقتي الغير متزوجه بحصر الارث
وخاصه انه ما في اخ يحجب وقانون القرد
المتبعه في كنائسنا في الاردن يعتمد على
الشريعه الاسلاميه وقواعدها الفقهيه
[موسيقى]
لست انا فقط منتضرر من هذا الموضوع هناك
العشرات غيري اللواتي اليوم وكل يوم
يتضررنا ويقعنا ضحيه لعدم تغيير القانون
مثل اموريم وبناتها الثلاث فبعد وفاه
زوجها عانت السيده في ميراث زوجها وحفظ حق
بناتها فيه لتامين مستقبلهن ام ريم تعيش
في مدينه الحصن شمال الاردن توجهنا لها
لنعرف التفاصيل زوجي هو من نفس العيله
قارب يعني في 94 تعرفنا مزبوط على بعض
وتزوجنا
طبعا
خلفنا ثلاث صبايا
كبروا الصبايا كبروا البنات
بتعرفي كيف انا واياه بنشتغل انا كنت في
الخدمات الطبيه وهو كمان كان يشتغل في
الاثار فكنا نحط القرش على القرش يعني
تنصير قررنا انه ناخذ قرض
ونشتري هذا البيت سكنا هون في البيت
تقريبا عشر ايام
شكى من صدره
نقلنا على المستشفى من ضمن الفحوصات اللي
عملها طلع عنده كانسر منتشر هو نفسه شاف
حاله تعبان
بحكي لي نادي لي ريم عن بنته الكبيره
فنادت بحكي لها بابا
فعلا يوم الاحد الصبح
الساعه 12 وشوي بالليل يعني احد على اثنين
توفى مالحه
فهون سقطت الوكاله
انا ما بلوم لاشخاص ولا بدين اشخاص
انا عتباني على القانون
عتباني على القانون اللي مش انا بس
ناس كثير مثلي
[موسيقى]
يعني ماشيين على القانون وماشيين على
وصايا الرب صح ولا لا ايش معنى هاي الشغله
شغله الارث احنا مش قادرين نحصلها